Transcriptor: Cristina Juesas
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
[Música]
Estoy seguro que habéis visto
esta imagen miles de veces.
Lo que os pido es que hoy la veamos
con los ojos nuevos
para intentar descubrir mayores matices.
Yo la utilizo mucho en talleres
con profesorado y pregunto:
¿para qué utilizaríais
esta imagen en una clase?
Los primeros, los más racionales,
que son los que responden al principio,
dicen: “pues para hablar del
consumo energético del mundo,”
o “para hablar de
la densidad poblacional”
o también hay quien dice
“pues con esto podríamos hablar
de la historia colonial”
o “del efecto del clima y de la orografía
en los asentamientos humanos”.
Cuando ya vamos entrando en calor
llegamos a la gente
que tiene un poco más
de capacidad de profundizar
y dicen: “esta es la imagen
perfecta para hablar
de la desigualdad en el mundo”
o, por ejemplo, “para expresar
la paradoja del origen
y el consumo de los recursos naturales”
o “para hablar del
creciente proceso de urbanización
en el que estamos metidos en el mundo”.
O esta que me gusta mucho,
que dice “nos serviría muy bien
para hablar de la relación
entre desarrollo y movilidad humana”.
Me encanta esta imagen
porque nos permite ver claramente
las diferentes lecturas que podemos
hacer de una misma mirada,
las distintas profundidades que
podemos hacer de la misma realidad.
Y fijaros que siempre,
en todos los talleres que hago,
al final, casi con timidez y despacito,
alguien se atreve a decir:
“yo la utilizaría para preguntar
qué es lo que sabemos
de aquellos sitios donde no hay luz”.
Os reto a pensar mentalmente
cuál es este país y cuál es su capital,
o por ejemplo este otro
¿qué régimen político tiene?
¿algún pensador famoso
que haya tenido influencia?
o este otro: ¿cuál es el recurso
principal que tiene su economía?
o por ejemplo ¿cuál ha sido el
último conflicto que han vivido?
Estaréis conmigo que hay muchísimas
realidades de las que apenas sabemos nada.
Y es normal, pero es
importante hacerse esta pregunta:
¿de qué sé?, ¿sobre qué leo?,
¿de qué hablo cuando tomo
café con mis amigos y mis amigas?,
¿de qué puedo decir que
estoy más o menos al tanto?,
¿qué es lo que me mueve
cuando busco información?
Esto es importantísimo
para aquellos que, por ejemplo,
tenéis familia o trabajamos
en medios de comunicación o en educación.
Filosóficamente la pregunta sería:
¿cómo me relaciono con la realidad
que va más allá de mi contexto?
Y esto es importantísimo,
porque la pregunta en el fondo es:
¿qué mundo transmitimos
a las generaciones más jóvenes?
¿de qué les hablamos?
o, más bien, ¿de qué no hablamos?
y, por lo tanto, quizá estemos
perpetuando estas zonas de sombra
que a nadie le importan,
de las que nadie sabe,
lugares a los que nadie mira.
Esto es bien normal, ocurre mucho
en la historia de la humanidad.
Es bien difícil ser consciente,
o interpretar, situaciones
y eventos históricos
cuando uno los está viviendo.
Hace bien poco veíamos
en las noticias, y nos escandalizaba,
que la mediados del siglo XIX,
aquí en España, teníamos
anuncios en prensa
en los que se vendían esclavos.
Nos parece alucinante.
O, por ejemplo, hace unos años
me fui en coche desde mi casa
hasta Auschwitz, sólo para unir
mi realidad con uno de los
episodios más oscuros
de la historia de la humanidad.
Que pese a que lo estudiamos
en los libros de historia ha ocurrido,
como quien dice ayer,
a unas 20 horas en coche
desde aquí, desde Vitoria.
¿No es flipante?
O algo mucho más cercano,
el muro de Berlín.
Todavía recuerdo en el 89
cuando cayó el muro,
estar viendo las noticias.
Me parece cuando menos
sorprendente, el pensar
cómo la población coetánea
de ese momento pudo
convivir con la existencia
de estos 160 km
de muro y de vallas que
durante 26 años dividieron
a la población,
impidiendo su libre circulación.
Más de 100 mil personas
intentaron saltar esta valla.
Muchas de ellas fueron
detenidas, algunas perecieron.
Esto ha ocurrido muchísimo
en la historia de la humanidad:
Poblaciones enteras han vivido
durante mucho tiempo
ignorando realidades
bien visibles que, luego,
con la luz del tiempo y de la historia,
hemos calificado
de injusticias sangrantes.
¡Qué difícil es interpretar la realidad
cuando somos parte de ella!, ¿verdad?
No sé si conocéis esta ciudad,
es una ciudad española.
Bonita foto, bonita ciudad.
Es Ceuta, está en el lado
africano del estrecho de Gibraltar.
Son 18 km cuadrados
del territorio separados de Marruecos
por una valla de 8 km de largo
y 6 m de altura.
Y os tengo que confesar que
la mitad de las fotos que he puesto
cuando hablaba del muro
de Berlín eran de nuestra valla de Ceuta.
Una valla que está funcionando
en este momento,
que está sostenida
con nuestros impuestos,
que está defendida
por nuestras fuerzas de seguridad.
Es nuestro país.
En esta valla se da el salto de PIB
más grande del mundo.
Es la frontera en la que se da
el salto de PIB más grande del mundo.
Fue construida en el año 98
con fondos paradójicamente llamados,
de la Unión Europea,
para el desarrollo regional.
¿Os dáis cuenta de la paradoja?:
para crear el espacio Schengen
y tener una Europa sin fronteras,
nos vemos obligados a crear
la frontera más desigual del mundo,
en la que en este momento
estamos frenando las expectativas,
las ilusiones, los caminos, de miles
de personas que están escapando
de la pobreza, de la injusticia,
de la persecución, de la guerra.
Estoy convencido que en el futuro
alguien, en una charla como ésta,
mirará hacia atrás y dirá: ¡cómo
pudieron vivir tranquilos y tranquilas
con semejante vulneración
de derechos en su patio trasero
Esto es por lo que me gusta
llevar a la gente joven a Ceuta,
porque cuando descubren
la valla uno puede apreciar en sus ojos
cómo cambia para siempre
su percepción de nuestro mundo.
Es como si al darse cuenta de que
nuestro concepto de estado del bienestar
está apoyado en semejante
barrera de contención,
cambia para siempre
la forma en la que entendemos el mundo.
Es lo mismo en el “Show de Truman,”
no sé si visteis la película.
Cuando el protagonista escapa
en el velero y choca contra el decorado,
y todo lo que hasta ese momento
había sido el mundo para él,
se da cuenta de que se trata
de un escenario, de un plató de TV.
Conocer la valla de Ceuta o de Melilla,
para la gente joven,
equivale a este despertar
a la complejidad del mundo,
es añadir un nivel más de profundidad
a la interpretación de ese mapamundi,
es iluminar una zona que estaba a oscuras.
Y una vez que se descubre,
ya no hay marcha atrás.
Esto es lo que llamamos
conciencia de ciudadanía global,
por la que todos y todas
deberíamos de pasar.
esto está yendo a más.
Si en el año 89 cuando cayó el muro
de Berlín había 16 muros y vallas
en fronteras exteriores del mundo,
el año pasado contabilizábamos ya 70.
Sólo en la Unión Europea hemos
construido, en los últimos 30 años,
casi 1000 km de vallas y muros exteriores.
De ellos, 2 vallas en nuestro país:
18,7 km.
Pese a que los expertos
dicen una y otra vez
que esta no es manera
de gestionar los flujos migratorios,
en los últimos cinco años
se han construido
25 nuevos muros y vallas en el mundo,
más que en ningún otro período
de la edad moderna.
Y lo curioso es que estas vallas o estos
muros son simbólicos más que reales,
porque no son eficientes,
y está comprobado que no disuaden
y mucho menos resuelven el problema
de la movilidad forzosa o
de la movilidad humana.
Lo que ocurre es que mueven
los flujos a otros lugares
normalmente a rutas
más inseguras con mayor peligro.
En el año 2016 se batió
el récord de muertes de personas
cruzando una frontera en el mundo: 7200.
De ellas 5000 en nuestro
querido Mediterráneo.
¡Vaya si nos toca de cerca este problema!
En este momento 1 de cada 13 personas
que intenta
cruzar de Libia hasta Italia, fallece.
Pensemos bien ¿quién en su
cordura es capaz de jugarse la vida
con semejante probabilidad,
salvo que esté a la desesperada?
Son personas, igual que
a nosotros nos escandaliza
hablar de la esclavitud o
de los campos de concentración,
nos van a mirar y van a decir:
"¿pero no se dieron cuenta
de que eran seres humanos?"
La única manera en la que
estamos conviviendo con esta situación,
fijaros bien, es
porque los tenemos a oscuras,
porque no tienen rostro,
no tienen nombre,
no tienen historia, no hay relación.
No nos importan.
Por eso es tan importante poner luz, ser
conscientes, experimentar, crear relación.
Porque si fueran nuestra familia,
o nuestros conocidos,
os aseguro que encontraríamos
la manera de solucionar esta situación.
Así que dejarme que lo diga bien claro:
el concepto actual de frontera
que manejamos es inhumano,
y en el futuro se escandalizará de
la forma en la que estamos abordando
la movilidad humana en un mundo
donde cada vez hay más vallas,
cada vez hay más muros, cada vez
hay más fronteras contra personas.
La clave está en nuestra conciencia
de ser parte de la familia humana,
¿quién es mi gente? y ¿por qué ellos no?,
y la conciencia de ciudadanía global:
¿hasta dónde llega aquello de lo que
yo me siento responsable?
y ¿por qué de esto no?
Así que ojalá que la próxima vez
que vayamos a buscar qué libro leer,
o sobre qué leer en internet,
o de qué vamos a hablar en el próximo
café con nuestros amigos y amigas,
recordemos la enorme
fuerza que podemos tener
sólo trayendo luz sobre
la movilidad humana
que es una de las grandes
causas sociales de nuestra era.
Sin duda uno de los mayores errores
colectivos de nuestro tiempo.
Y no olvidéis la enorme fuerza que tiene
la toma de conciencia colectiva
de forma progresiva,
porque a lo largo de la humanidad
ha demostrado
ser la más importante fuerza
para el cambio,
capaz de tumbar y derribar
muros y barreras
que en su tiempo parecían imposibles.
Así que pongamos luz en esta situación.
Depende de ti, depende de mí,
depende de todos.
Abramos los ojos. Es nuestro tiempo.
Que no nos digan que no nos dimos cuenta.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)